des centaines de chefs venus de toute la
france mais aussi de nombreux pays
étrangers vêtus de leur veste blanche de
cuisiniers ont rendu un dernier hommage
à paul bocuse
une cérémonie empreinte de solennité
mais non dénué d'humour paul lashawn
d'arriver à gérer est en peine elle
déborde de tristesse mais nous ne serons
pas triste
tu n'aurais pas aimé toi qui t amuser
toute ta vie
l'ancien maire de lyon et actuel
ministre de l'intérieur était également
présent vous incarniez la gastronomie
vous incarnez la france dans son
excellence mais au plus profond de votre
coeur
il y avait votre ville notre ville
[Musique]
et c'est sous les applaudissements de
ses pairs que paul bocuse a quitté pour
une dernière fois la cathédrale de sa
ville à l'extérieur sous la pluie le
public avait pu suivre la cérémonie sur
des écrans géants
c'est un grand chef quand même un grand
chef il a exporté beaucoup lire on
paiera une grande personne mais sur sur
la france sur le monde il a rayonné par
l exporter la critique
après l'inhumation les 1100 invités
présents dans la cathédrale se sont
retrouvés dans le restaurant de paul
bocuse ici frédéric nicoloff
radio-canada moria